[Music]  at a brexit council form of a mission  when ye informed us about the current  state of the negotiations we are in a  crucial phase definitely but so far  progress is not sufficient to call in  and set up another council and we're  waiting for further progress afterwards  we had as I said article 7 procedures  concerning Poland Hungary followed by a  very fruitful and long debate on rule of  law generally in Europe which is an  absolutely important topic for everybody  there is an utmost understanding that  this is absolutely key for the future of  the European Union followed by a long  dialogue and exchange of views on the  multi-annual financial framework where  we have come some steps forward and we  now are preparing a progress paper which  will be the basis for the first  political discussion of the heads of  states on the MFF  in December  [Music]  you  [Music]